ceausescus und herzlich willkommen zur
vorstellung der neuen ender games kids
wir schauen uns heute das kit spion 1
so dass wir wieder und bevor wir
loslegen machen wir erst mal einen
kurzen blick wir machen einen pkw werfen
einen blick auf die beschreibung die
leute wie folgt der spio und statt mit
einem weißem brustpanzer und kann sich
durch schnieken komplett unsichtbar
machen hierbei verliert der hunger er
ist so lange unsichtbar bisher von einem
gegner schaden erleidet oder keine hohe
kollmer besitzt somit ausgewählt sehr
gut das bedeutet wir haben eine weiße
leder jazzband einer brüssels punkte
ganz in ordnung haben aber keine buhs
anders als bei assassine oder mofa kein
leder boots es ist kritisch weil man
dann ja theoretisch unfallschaden
sterben kann wenn man wenn man liegt
auch wenn man es nicht sonst gibt ja
diese diesen trick dass man einfach
nicht muss man kriegt manchmal von
verzögern gut funktioniert nicht weil
wir keine busam wir können uns
unsichtbar machen indem wir schiff
drücken und das ist das haupt feature
des billion kids wie verlieren
allerdings sehr schnell wenn wir uns
unsichtbar machen wirklich sehr schnell
das ist relativ schlecht also es geht
wirklich intakt sagt ja so ungefähr
dafür dem herzen jetzt auch gleich sehen
aber wir können eine tolle sache machen
uns heute hier achtung so sind wir
wissen ja ok klasse h ich muss wirklich
erwachsen werden okay alles gut ich
würde sagen wir legen dann einfach mal
los wir ausgewählt haben einen guten
anfang bekommt
wie immer gilt ich werde die runden
möglichst so hoch lagen wie ich gespielt
habe
mal schauen ob wir diese rolle gewinnen
bekommen muss man mal schauen
so habe ich das recht seine images
gesehen
ob das ding trifft ja ging sogar einfach
ein eisen in der mara fucking musste man
halt machen
mit einem eisen da kann man nichts
machen leute
der ist doch nicht so toll das ist doch
nicht so gut
das ist doch scheiße wir können jetzt
durch den anruf machen
ok tut mir leid ist bereit für die
menschheit aber es tut mir wirklich leid
hätte aber ich bin grad eine aufnahme
ich habe es gerade zum ersten mal
gemacht in meinem ganzen spiel seitdem
ich gerne games spiele und es tut mir
wirklich leid ich schäme mich dafür
aber ich bin davon aufnahme ist muss
meine jolo machen und dass uns das nicht
weiter von belasten
20 beim anti laster
er sieht es nicht mehr sie ist dann
siehst dann santina siehst du siehst du
uns ist uns los ist du uns
wahrscheinlich wasser gehen ist anttila
soap stars anna schlecht schläft
schlecht den 28 gramm
nein es war keine gute entscheidung das
war keine gute entscheidung wer von
salida weckt uns unsichtbar machen
können das war wirklich meister muss
jetzt glaube ich allen dann nämlich den
letzten ja wohl so kann man doch mal
spionen spiel ganz ehrlich das macht
doch bock geil richtig nice läuft läuft
auf jeden fall bei uns das war nicht
cool haben wirklich gut gefallen so das
war zum beispiel eine einsatzmöglichkeit
von spiel und kit stellt mit keinem
anderen kittler durchgekommen vielleicht
mit känguru wenn man wegläuft aber sonst
wird gar keinen aber wir mit dem spiel
gehabt jetzt gemeistert und das muss ich
sagen gefällt mir gerade richtig gut
das gefällt mir gerade richtig gut hier
bisher gar zu boykott spielen kehrt es
eigentlich nichts tolles aber das war
eigentlich eine echt coole sache keiner
kann man natürlich sagen öl abgestaubt
oder so aber so ist es halt
okay man munkelt man hätte jetzt ja auch
eine eisen ladies machen können aber ich
habe lieber gold an den beinen ihr wisst
bescheid
so jetzt wer nicht ganz so ausgerüstet
die hatten nämlich ja wer mehr herzblut
von fachleuten abgegriffen könne schon
schlimmer hier die levels per 23 und
dann würde ich sagen legen wir los
es ist als spion übrigens ganz wichtig
dass hier unten in der in der haut war
immer ein platz frei habt weil weil ganz
ganz wichtig ihr dürft auf gar keinen
fall was in der hand halten
wenn ihr euch unsichtbar macht sie
deutlich was in der hand halten dann ist
die ganze platte spaß und sonst richtung
verzaubern aber kein bock nicht dass du
dein gepostet werden da kein experte an
wir vertrauen euch sowieso nicht so oft
verzaubert werden meine schwester und
meine bögen weil die dann wirklich
brutal sparen mache schauen wir mal ob
teams sieht
denn da hinten sich damals zu dem rummel
ist das war noch ein sack und danach ist
benny ist gar nicht neu
geil auf jeden fall habe ich einfach
ersten kreisrats aber schlecht das war
richtig schlecht das war richtig richtig
schlecht jetzt nicht bank im boden wagen
nicht den boden banken rennen laufen
rennen nicht gut
warum denn die was ist das für eine
range nein und er hat einfach wasser
platziert
aber die aber das war auf jeden fall
habe der mutter am anfang mehr so gut
gefangen mit dem spiel gefallen und ich
denke das wird einfach immer
weitermachen
der wird von hinten gekippt tja so ist
das leben er lieber und ich wir sind der
nächsten runde wieder
bis gleich so leute so wieder zweite
runde es geht direkt weiter nachdem die
erste runde jetzt erst so gut angefangen
also ein jähes ende genommen hat weil
diese delfinen den ungespritzten gemacht
hat mit den wassereimer schader wieling
los so schön direkt das eisen gold
sauber
alles klar schaue mir die nächsten
länder tests sind da vorne ist eine sehr
gut wer weiß müsse da sie quasi nichts
mit anfangen aber besser als gar nichts
würde ich mal sagen wir scheinbar
denkmal weiter ein energies kann man
noch 1000 nehmen alles klar
dann kann man es gerade die nachricht
ist ein so reiches beschreibt anfangs
kräften arbeiten durch die comcom
bekommt sie sterben
vor 11 uhr ist da wo ist dann ist er
vorne also falls eine helferin will
alles klar
go go go go go go go go go spionierte
sie alle da draußen was niemanden leben
doch vor das höchste ok sehr gut der hat
keine große herausforderung nächste da
jetzt aber wieder mega viel abschnitt
bis zum nächsten freitag wird das mal
schön und mit gold lage zu machen
und eigentlich auch brot großes trainer
olsen brothers sommer relativ jeden fall
stark dafür dass wir so ein schöner
sport machen
ok spaß team modus beenden und mein
wissen weiter zocken
wir halten uns mal den slot hier frei
damit wir darauf switchen können und uns
unsichtbar machen können also ins lot
neben den kompass habe jetzt mal frei
gemacht weil ihr wisst ja man darf
nichts in der hand halten wenn man sich
als spion versteckt wird man gesehen
eine web frei
so gesehen wird es natürlich ein
bisschen scheiße oder einzel
überraschungseffekt hin und der gegner
überrascht ein weil man denkt man kann
ich gesehen
die erschwert nämlich kaisheimer switch
gerade jetzt als ich den alten angreifen
wollte aber ich freue mich eigentlich
beschweren 150 blöcke alte dass immer
einer richtig weg richtig weit entfernt
150 blöcke einfach da facto känguru was
die ganze zeit wegläuft oder nichts ging
kein groß aber wir nähern uns mal dem
jetzt wird langsam spannender 80 bürger
50 blöcke 40 auf pascal emre da vorne
ist seht schon
der delfin diese kalte wasser
moment moment warum geht unter wasser
moment ist wahrscheinlich ein heil sowie
selbst unsichtbar was da los
wo alter konnte das team nicht zu alter
richtig glückliche switch gegeben sehr
gut sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut
ok es noch bisschen abstand auf den
nächsten alter das war jetzt wirklich
brenzlig das war wirklich eine brenzlige
situation gerade im kreis erst fast
gestorben ist ein analoger mit ihr noch
gegeben knapp okay okay alles leisten
aber ich mal dragon der weise kann man
nicht so in reagans nicken als spion man
einfach so schnell hunger punkte
verliert ein notebook schwerter ist doch
kapke dabei noch backstage doch gar
nicht so schlecht eigentlich recht gut
mit combo unglaublich das sollte schon
gehen
pascal m räder hinten diese sniper
master ist eigentlich ziemlich gute
cryptic mir sagen lassen bis sie das
habe ich selbst gesehen
vielleicht wollen wir zum abschluss
nochmal in spielzeug ausprobieren was
meint ihr wird sein wir können
eigentlich fast so machen
er kommt auf uns zu
oder doch nicht kann entscheiden wo wir
auf ihn zuging
gutes essen
liebesleid post
ein spion sniper macht das einspielen
des teams auftauchen
das heißt wir können nicht ewig unter
wasser bleiben
kurz darauf traf auf doch auch drauf
ja sehr gut sehr gut sauber ok direkt
mit dem spione runde gewonnen ist habe
ich die erste vorstellung ich mal
gewinne und ich würde sich gefallen hat
dann lasst einen daumen nach oben da
statt in die kommentare die kids als
nächstes sehen wollte würde ich sagen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
hat einen schönen tag
haut rein und schön